Hello, everyone. You may have noticed,
I live in England and
it's the middle of winter.
It's freezing.
So I'm gonna warm myself up today
with a lot of cups of tea, delicious.
Nah , it's not true.
What I'm doing is,
you may have noticed that all
the descriptions of the videos
I always write filmed at,
a thousand FPS or something,
and the FPS stands for frames per second.
Basically our high speed camera,
the higher the frame rate,
the slower the motion.
Is how many pictures it's
taking in one second basically.
So I'm gonna smash these mugs
at 500, a thousand, 2,500
and 5000 frames a second.
They're all pretty common
frame rates to my channel
if you've seen previous videos.
But there's one frame
rate I'm going to do today
that I've never done
before on the channel.
10,000 frames a second.
It has to be a reduced resolution,
but we'll see how it turns out.
I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be horribly slow.
But we'll see.
All right, this is where we
do quite a lot of our filming,
but as you can see, it's winter.
So the sun is so low.
Even on a sunny day,
the sun never actually
touches the ground here.
So I'm gonna have to
do this somewhere else.
Now the reason I have to
do this in the sunlight,
is because as you'll notice,
as the frame rate goes up,
the light goes down.
Gets darker and darker
as you shoot faster.
And at 10,000 frames,
it's pretty freaking dark.
All right, well, now we have
a good speed comparison.
Thanks to these poor innocent mugs.
Before I turn this off, I'm gonna say,
go and watch "Sherlock
Holmes" the second movie,
"A Game of Shadows"
because I worked on it
and there's a ton of slow motion in it.
Shot with this exact camera
that I use for the slow-mo guys.
So watch the movie,
let me know what you think of the slow-mo.
I honestly think is probably,
one of the most mental
action scenes I've ever seen.
So let me know what you think.
See you later.